welcome i'm angela mcdonald from udacity
i'm one of the career coaches
maybe some of us have had a session
together or maybe you've met with some
of our other coaches
also on today we've got yvonne who's one
of our coaches you might have had a
session with her
and she will also be here to help me out
i'm super excited about this session
today
a little bit quick about me because this
really isn't about me but just so you
know a little bit of my background
before being a coach
i was also an expat for many years 16
years abroad
spent time in australia china and
singapore
and part of what happened to me in all
of those different moves and then
back to america is is having to relaunch
my career in some way shape or form
and so it's really a a topic that i love
to talk about and helping
people after they've taken a break
whether it's been an expat break
or a maternity break or staying home
with uh their own health issues
whatever it is that's caused us maybe to
have a gap in our career
and coming back and relaunching so today
we are going to talk to the expert of
the relaunch
her name is carol fishman cohen carol
thanks so much for coming
i'm going to share before i let you talk
i'm going to share a little bit get a
little bragging on about you
and let people see a little bit about
what you do if they haven't looked at it
yet
carol is the chair and co-founder of
ireland
it's the pioneering company in the
re-entry space
they work with hundreds of companies on
building return to work initiatives so
instead of just
helping job seekers maybe such as
yourself find the jobs and find ways to
get back to work
they actually have been super proactive
going to these companies and saying hey
you need a structure in place you need
something that you can do to
to really encourage these people to come
back so i think it's fantastic she's
written a book she's going to share a
lot of her resources
and something i'm really excited for her
to talk about today is the
the stem reentry task force with the
society of women engineers which is
obviously carol with the the stem
experts we have on here
they will have a lot of interest in that
stem piece so i am going to stop
sharing so we can just focus on carol
and what she has to say
and let it go from here and and as
questions
do come up if they come to your mind
just type them in the chat
and we'll have some time to get to
questions at the end and we'll catch as
many of those as we can so carol
i'll let you go ahead and give a little
more of an introduction i hope i did
okay and giving the a little bit of
background but
tell us a little bit about yourself and
starting ire lunch
all right well thanks angela and thanks
to udacity for having me
as a guest i'm excited to be interacting
with all of you
who are here online with us so i'm carol
fishman cohen i'm the chair and
co-founder of i relaunch
and we are the pioneering company in the
career reentry
space we started in 2007
uh and before that and leading to
co-founding i relaunch
i co-authored a book called back on the
career track
which came out in 2007 and
is known as the bible of career reentry
uh
and even before that i lived this myself
so just as angela's talking about her
relaunch experience
i am a financial analyst by trade i was
working in corporate finance for an
investment bank in boston
and my company collapsed when i was on
maternity leave with my first child
and so i didn't have a company to return
to and that began my career break i
decided
not to go looking for the next big job i
ended up having three more kids i was
home with them
for 11 years and then and that was in
a long time ago that the company
collapsed 11 years later in 2001
i relaunched my career again as a
financial analyst
uh at uh bain capital which is a big
investment firm that's here in boston
and it was in part because there were
people
who remembered me from 11 years before
who had worked with me at the investment
bank
and they they they remembered me years
later and
and gave me the opportunity to come in
and speak with them and that ultimately
led to the job opportunity so
i've been through every phase of this
transition first hand
and that is really helps me have an
authentic connection
to our audience that i relaunch which is
at this point 82 000 people nationally
men and women who are returning to work
after queer breaks for
child care elder care expat experiences
uh it could be retirees uh a personal
health issue pursuing a personal passion
we also have some veterans and military
spouses that
that are relaunching careers so uh
people who are on career breaks from one
to over 20 years
in every field and then as angela talked
about
we do a lot of our work with companies
to create
their own in-house return to work
programs
many of them are internship based they
call them return ships we can talk about
that
um and that originated because origin
because and we can talk about how this
has evolved but companies
uh perceived hiring relaunchers people
who are returning after career breaks
as a high risk proposition so the
return ship the internship allowed
a for a testing out period before having
to make that hiring decision and
that's been a really successful model uh
and we'll talk about
the statistics that we have from the
stem re-entry task force because we have
many companies involved in that
on in that initiative that launch
programs and we keep statistics on how
many people get hired afterwards so we
can talk about that
but then we're also seeing other types
of return to work programs
for example direct hire programs where
people are
hired into their role from day one there
is no internship
but there is still some transitional
programming
and a loose cohort of people who are
starting around the same time
and mentors uh and other um
support uh supports for them as they're
reintegrating in the first few months
back
and then the third um way we work with
companies
is to be involved in return to work
events
so maybe they screen and select 25 or 40
or 50 people
to come to a one or two day workshop
where we present career entry strategies
and they talk about their company and
then they use that as a pool to hire
from
so that that's what uh what we've been
seeing and
you know we've been watching this space
carefully since
2007 and one of the things we do is
document
uh the career reentry activity
um that's been going on and probably our
most
popular list on our ireland.com website
is a list we keep of about over 90
companies that
have a paid return to work program of
some kind and i should mention those
return ships are paid
uh so i would recommend people go to
ireland.com
and if you look under the relauncher tab
there is a something called paid
corporate return to work programs around
the world and you'll see that list
so that's an introduction great thank
you carol that's excellent
and i think that when you know a couple
things you mentioned there's and i feel
like i could talk to you all day about
it but one thing you said that really
struck me is
is that in the past and probably you
know
definitely when you were looking at rely
relaunching and even just
10 years ago even i feel like there's a
lot that's changed in the last five
years
and they used to really think of people
as being such a high risk and you would
just
avoid ever how can i hide that gap
what do i do to pretend that five years
never happened
can you share with us a little bit about
how that mindset shift
is changing in corporations and where
you see some of that progress and that
mind shift
happening so it's been really
fascinating to watch because angela
you're absolutely right
it used to be you had a career break on
your resume and it got tossed right into
the trash can
and now one of the first milestones that
we had was when we started to get a
critical mass
of these return to work programs most of
which involved the internship
structure and we were realizing
that all of a sudden you had to have a
career break in order to be
eligible to apply and and uh participate
in these programs so we thought wow
you really come full circle and in fact
you have to make your career break very
clear
on your resume in order to to uh
participate
and then the and and so i actually we
were
watching the emergence of these
returnship programs
for uh for a couple of years and i ended
up writing an article that
we can point to later for harvard
business review called the 40 year old
intern and it came out in 2012
eight years ago and that was when we
were really seeing this concept emerge
now what we've seen since then that has
that that we're tracking now
is that we're seeing some of the
programs that started as
a return ship model are transitioning
into a direct hire program
if you ask the managers why that is
happening
they say they'll say well we have really
high conversion rates out of these
programs we hire most of people
we're watching all the other companies
around us with high conversion rates
and we're starting to think that maybe
it's not that as risky as we thought
and so that risk quotient has been
decreasing over time
um and the other thing that's happening
is that we're getting
a more and more and a critical mass of
relaunchers
inside companies and so the more success
stories there are the more employers
that uh
have come to meet you know a number of
classes of relaunchers who have come
through their program
the more comfortable they're getting and
they not only comfortable
but they're seeing this is a very high
caliber population and we should really
be
harnessing this population so maybe it
started as a diversity initiative
because this population is
90 female but but
over time these programs often expand
based on their merit
just because of the caliber the people
that are coming the door and
and working at the company because of
the program
yeah and i think one one thing that i
will um add to that just so
if there are some of you on here that
are thinking right now well i haven't
had a career break should i stay on this
webinar i think
there's still a even if you don't
qualify for a very
specific relaunch program and carol talk
a little bit about what some of those
look like
they could be very structured programs
just like you would imagine an
internship and
they might want to require a three-year
career break
there's still a lot of things that you
can listen to in here and i
what i also think a lot of times if
there's a company out there
that has a relaunch program that's
probably a company i want to work for
even if i don't qualify maybe for that
specific
program i could still that could be a
company
if i was in your shoes as a stem
re-entry say okay maybe i don't qualify
for that program
but that's a company i'm going to target
because those values are
there and i think that's something to to
a reason to kind of stay on and listen
to more of what carol has to say and
look into ireland
and target some of those companies and
see what they're doing
can i just make one comment on that
angela um for people who are not on
career break but
maybe you're earlier in your career and
you're either anticipating a future
career break
or you don't really know because
sometimes these career breaks
are not planned for and they'll be
something that happens
on in your life and it becomes a reason
for you to take a career break sometimes
that's something
really happy and sometimes it's it's
some kind of an issue with
with your own health or have a special
needs child or infertility or something
um and uh and so one thing to keep in
mind
is if there's even a remote possibility
of taking a future career break there
are a couple of things you can be doing
right now
that will ease your transition back in
later if you end up taking a career
break so let me just get those on the
table so so
so people can be aware number one yeah
number one
is to start documenting so you're in
your job in real time right now
open up an e-file and start taking notes
about
milestone moments that you are
experiencing
positive negative any time you learn
something because you later on if you do
take a career break
when you're returning to work one of the
things that you need to be able to do
is to recount anecdotes from your prior
work experience
that are relevant to the job that you're
applying for and so those of us who
didn't take notes along the way
essentially have to recreate the past
and remember
um you know details from certain
situations
uh and you know put that together years
later
whereas if you're recording it in the
moment you
your post career break will thank you
for doing that now
the other thing that i would recommend
is to
nurture your relationships and you're
probably already doing that
maybe you know with your your boss your
manager
with peers in your organization but be
cognizant of the people who are junior
to you
who um report to you whom you mentor or
who you just know
because if you do go on career break
these junior people
could be moving up while you're on
career break and they can later be in a
position to open a door for you
and i can tell you in my own case when i
was on that investment
in the investment banking job before my
career break
i had gotten my mba i was the mba person
on the team there was someone
who was an analyst right out of college
on on
a couple of my teams and we knew each
other and when i took my 11-year career
break he was moving up
he became a managing director at bain
capital he's the one who opened the door
for me to go interview there and we have
numerous um
instances of relaunchers who are working
for people who used to work for them
so i'm just giving a little advance a
notice to think about
these junior people could become um
important and
if you have this great relationship with
them they're going to love the idea
that they can um like pay back for
whatever role you paid for that
you played for them initially now
they're able to
help you i love that i think that's such
a good point and you know i
i know we talk so much about networking
and relationships and
and it's important for not always right
now or when you're looking for a job but
you never know when those relationships
are going to come back
where you can help someone or someone
can help you so keeping that at the
always at the top of your mind and
that you know that term networking
doesn't mean you're out there at events
every day
passing out business cards it means
you're building those relationships with
people
right next to you under you and above
you so i think that's a great point
yeah and you know we do a podcast and we
can talk about this later
but um my last three podcasts and i and
i just wrote a piece on this because i
was so
struck that i had um a version of this
conversation three times in a row um
because
we released them every week so i'm
always recording them um
and three people in a row were talking
about who the person was who was
instrumental in their relaunch and it
was
always someone who they didn't know that
well you hear that the people who are
instrumental in your
relaunch are going to be people you
don't know that well so
illustration one person says
well my husband had lunch with someone
who knew someone who knew someone
that there was this potential opening
that was coming up in this it was at a
university
and i ended up going over there for an
informational interview and ended up
getting hired
or someone um was running this warrior
fun
run and with their friend and at the
last minute his other friend came along
who the person didn't even know
and they somehow ended up talking and
the relauncher ended up working for that
person
so you just don't do not know when these
relationships are going to
materialize or become significant
right and it could if you're doing a lot
of volunteer work
during your break sometimes those
relationships end up being what happens
and i think
you know i worked with someone i was
knew someone recently said they weren't
a client
and i knew she wanted to go back to work
so we were just having really a casual
chat over a glass of wine
and in the process she was telling me
she was going back to work some
circumstances had changed and she said
but i've done nothing
i've done nothing angela for seven years
and i say you know your
personality doesn't strike me of someone
who's been sitting on the sofa eating
doritos doing nothing
so let's talk about what you've been
doing and really came down to it she had
been
so instrumental in helping run her
husband's business
like are you crazy anyone would take you
on to come in and
and whip their business into shape and
some operational standpoint and
she got her first job and now she's
under her second job and it just it
makes me really excited to
to help people think like think about
that gap and if and if covet has
unfortunately caused you to have be out
of a job and
you're experiencing a gap right now
start thinking like
what can i do during this time that that
i'm not gonna let the gap define me
i'm gonna let what i'm doing during this
gap define me a little bit more
it's such a good point um we talk about
this whole concept of strategic
volunteering
taking on vol intentionally taking on
volunteer roles that are related to your
career goals
and there are three on websites that are
databases
of volunteer opportunities one is
idealist.org
i-d-e-a-l-i-s-t dot org
one is volunteer match dot org
and those are role-based volunteer
opportunities
and then there's a third one called
catch a fire
c-a-t-c-h-a-f-i-r-e
catch fire.org and those are
project-based
opportunities and if you go into the
site you'll see it'll most of them are
remote
so they can be done right now virtually
and it will be
like instead of taking on a volunteer
role as grant writer for the
organization
maybe you do a project writing a single
grant
uh so you know instead of um
you know maybe you helped develop a
marketing campaign but you're not the
actual volunteer marketing
director so so the so that's
um something just to keep in mind
because you can have
um a section on your on your resume
recent and relevant coursework and
experiences or you can put
experience on your resume instead of
work experience and put the volunteer
role side by side with your paid roles
and the other the other function that
volunteer works substantive volunteer
work does
is it allows you to have a reference
from someone who's current
um because sometimes people get really
nervous if they've been out of the
workforce you know from 14 years ago
on how are they ever going to get that
reference i will say
that we've had this happen a number of
times where people say my boss
a will never remember me from 14 years
ago or b
if they do remember me they're gonna be
mad i haven't been in touch so i'm not
gonna get in touch
and we're like no you gotta at least try
and invariably
the person's thrilled to hear from them
and remembers them and
when they've been asked to write
references and they've been
you know from a significant manager
relationship they have totally
been regarded as as a reference that was
written recently yeah those are great
yeah i remember i
uh when i first found out i was moving
overseas and i thought i would never
quit my job for anything and
then my husband said it was sydney
australia and i said okay i think i'm
convinced
um i didn't have to twist my arm too
much and my my boss and i put wrote on a
paper napkin
having farewell drinks that i'd be back
in three years
obviously i wasn't 16 years later and i
still haven't made my way back to
charlotte north carolina
but he was the one who wrote me a
reference to get my job back in banking
in australia so
he didn't hold the three-year napkin
contract against
me that's great and can you talk a
little bit
because this is something i even you
know every time i talk to someone i try
to look at their unique situation on how
to
show the gap and we talk a lot about how
to talk
about the gap because i think once
you're in the door for an interview that
becomes
something else we can talk about but you
can there's a lot you can talk about but
sometimes just
how you just show the gap and how you
what you call it whether it's on
linkedin or with your resume
what do you think employers like to see
what do you hear that recruiters want to
see
yes um okay so we can i'd like to talk
about
how do you talk about the gap
effectively but showing the gap
on a resume so let's talk about two
scenarios
the first one is if you're applying to
one of these
formal return to work programs that are
a company that are at a company
where you have to have a career break in
order to be eligible
in that situation you want to make it
very clear you want to actually write
career break 2010 to the present
and then have if you know whatever
you've done during that career break
it can be career break to care for
children career break for elder care
reasons
and then have some bullet points um any
courses that you took
any significant volunteer roles if
you've done occasional consulting
um don't worry that that's going to
disqualify you because
most companies will be interpret their
eligibility
fairly loosely and occasional consulting
is going to be okay
but put occasional consulting as one of
the things that you were doing during
your career break
uh it could be carroll fishland cohen
consulting uh consulting
on marketing and communication strategy
and then maybe you know two or three
bullet points
about the you know the top
uh assignments that you had over even if
it's a multi-year period
okay so that is if you took a career
break and you want to make a
point of it because you're applying for
one of these return to work programs
now most people are not going to get
hired that way
and so the other way that you're going
to want to think about
what's your career break or how to
portray it on a resume
is if you really don't want to call it
out so much
um first of all you you know you have to
you have to tell the truth um and
sometimes people will say you know
i took a career break because i had
these caregiving responsibilities or
something else was going on my life not
so i could be doing activities to ease
my transition back in so
i didn't take any courses i didn't do
you know any volunteer work uh
so you know it's good to dive in like
you did with your client to find out
if they're saying i didn't really do
anything and they actually have done a
lot more than they're giving themselves
credit for
um but if they really don't have a lot
to of
you know career specifically
um then you're gonna have to write
career break
you know uh whatever whatever year uh to
the present
and say what it was for uh and
remember that you are unlikely
to get chosen from you know a linkedin
keyword search with with that resume
you you're not pro you may not but most
relaunchers
don't get uh they're not uh focused of
headhunters
they usually get their jobs because of a
personal connection or some sort of
personal handoff
and that's where you want to spend most
of your time is going public with your
job search and telling everyone you know
that you're interested in returning to
work and being very specific
about what you want to do and we can
talk about the career assessment piece
and why
you can't just say yeah i'm looking for
jobs in finance
you might want to say i just took a uh
a course in anti-money laundering and
i'm looking for compliance rules
so you see the specificity of
um of the goal is really really
important
um so uh if you have
done taken relevant courses and and if
you haven't been doing it during your
career brief you can start right now
enroll in a course take a volunteer role
and put reasoning relevant on coursework
and
and experience on top and list it
even if you started it recently uh yeah
you're currently
enrolled in you know this python course
or a project management course
uh and you are currently working on a
volunteer project
on you know whatever it is so so yeah i
would say um
you have to acknowledge the career break
if you haven't done any of this during
it
if you have like if you look at my
linkedin profile
during my career break i call it
community leader
that's what that's what i called it and
then underneath i
in the description i have these
different roles that i took as a
volunteer
at our community in our kids school um
and i think i might have even delineated
a couple of them you know
written a grant that got a grant that
was successful or
you know led a school redistricting
campaign pto president
you know those kinds of things so i just
called it community leader
good yeah and i think you know the
advantage that i think
uh most of our listeners and those here
today is being udacity students
you all have you're taking really tough
courses
and you need to give yourself credit for
that whether you started yesterday or
you're someone who's been maybe on your
third or fourth udacity course
you know be really proud of the fact
that you have that
really intense um classes you're doing
with
with robust projects that are going to
be really what you can leverage
to show that like okay maybe and and i
joke about sitting on the couch eating
doritos
but you know sometimes you were in a
situation where
you had to give 110 of everything you
had to to your kids or some an elderly
or
someone that was sicker yourself and you
couldn't do anything and that's don't
beat yourself up over that but start
today start tomorrow start as soon as
you can
get in these courses and start doing
what you want to do
to make that gap start to lessen
yes and i just want to make a comment on
these on the udacity courses so when
you're in these courses
this is a powerful signal to your future
employer
how serious you are about returning to
work because one of the most important
things that you need to do
is to become a subject matter expert all
over again
whether you're returning to your old
field or you're transitioning and you're
going into a new field
and this coursework leads the way
and these credentials now the most
important thing is to
finish the course uh and because i know
the completion rates
you know vary but finish the course um
or indicate if you're in the middle of
it
that that you're taking it uh because
you want it to be
uh you want to show how serious you are
and and that will help
and the other thing is if there is
something about the course where you're
creating a a portfolio
of certain projects that you're gonna
especially if they're
if they're technical um or if there's
some sort of
capstone project that's part of it you
can put that
as a separate entrance on your resume
entrance on your resume in addition
to the course itself and we have had
people who take
coursework that were engaged in some
sort of a field study or
a special project tell us they spent
more time
talking about the project then they
talked about the course and it was
really good conversation material at
professional association events and
especially in interviews
yeah i think that's a great point i've
seen a lot of resumes where
they want to convince someone that oh
this is
all about the class in the in the
university or the school or udacity
and you know i said scratch that you
could they can look that up they can you
can give them a one line but tell us
what you did what did you achieve
because these projects of you know
teaching
you know computer vision or some of
these courses are really it's
it's not light stuff and you're really
making a
a big improvement on your portfolio in
your whether it's in your github or
you're just listing it on your resume to
really show what you achieved
not this is about the class but what did
you achieve in that class
yes and those github portfolios are
really really
important um and to have
to have one and to have a range of
projects
in there uh because i've
talked to occasionally technical
relaunchers
who don't even know about github and i
tell them
you have to know exactly what github is
and you have to have one
if you're going to be viable in your
field so that's that's really important
yeah so um and i know i'm we're going to
go just so everyone knows we're going to
go into about 45 minutes after the hour
so you understand the timing
and we're going to keep talking here
we're going to start getting to
questions before we run out of time
also you the udacity coaches will be
holding a follow-up to this in a couple
weeks so we can
get to some more of the questions but i
maybe carol we shift over to
i i think where maybe some of us coaches
aren't as
clear and it's not our specialty is
one what it can you show us a little bit
more of what some of these relaunch
programs
getting into them looks like and how
your organization really helps people
find them and get into them okay
so why don't i use the stem re-entry
task force as an example
so we can talk about both topics at the
same time excellent okay
so um the stem re-entry task force is a
joint initiative that i relaunch
runs with the society of women engineers
and
it involves now 32 companies
each company that joins commits to
piloting
a formal in-house return to work program
of some kind
um in the active year that they're on
the task force and then after that
active year they become a task force
alum
and and we can talk about that in a
minute so um
usually that means that they're starting
a program that's either a return chip or
a direct hire program and so we've had
we have the 30 um 32 companies 23 of
them have started programs so far
and the programs that have been born out
of this initiative
are ibm tech reentry uh
general motors take two um
cummins re-power uh now united
technologies and raytheon were both in
it and they each had their own programs
and now they've merged
their raytheon technologies and they
have raytheon technologies
reimpower um johnson johnson's part of
it they have reignite
uh so we're you know uh
procter gamble has a proctor and gamble
relaunch
so um all of these programs um
involved uh are are specifically for
relaunchers
um if they have the return ship model
they that means that
people apply to join a cohort and it can
be hundreds of people that are applying
for maybe
anywhere from six to 35 spaces
okay and sometimes they're in a single
location and sometimes they're in
multiple locations
these return ships think about summer
internship programs for
university students tweaked for the
mid-career professional
and so they last anywhere from
eight weeks to nine months most of them
are between three months and six months
in length they're paid um sometimes
you're doing a project
in a particular area where they're
anticipating
there will be open head count when the
program ends
sometimes you're in an actual open head
count role right from the beginning
um even though you're it classified as
an
intern equivalent um and if you're
successful
then on a friday you're a return ship
person and on the monday you're still in
the same role but you're a full-fledged
employee
so um the opportunity is that you move
for the return ships you move through
the program as a group
uh and that's really helpful because you
know when i relaunched
i was this kind of unusual one-off hire
there i didn't know anyone else who had
relaunched
relaunching wasn't even a thing in 2001
um
but now when people are in this cohort
there's an orientation there's
programming
we at our relaunch do this really
popular kickoff how to make the most of
your career re-entry experience a half
day
um and then there'll be ongoing
programming maybe you have a lunch and
learn
with a senior executive who talks about
their career path
and also their line of business it could
be
other relaunchers in the company come
and have a panel with you and talk about
what it was like
to transition back to work at that
company um
we do something called cohort coaching
where we meet with the group
at the middle and right before their mid
reviews and at the end um right before
they find out if they're continuing or
not and we talk about
life after relaunch whether they're
going to be continuing or not continuing
so the idea that you go through this
process with a group and i actually have
an
article for heart that i wrote for
harvard business review called
the power of the cohort in career
reentry programming
because we're so unusual inside the
organization
that we get a lot of personal and
professional support from each other
as we're moving through it now the other
kinds of programs are
what i mentioned the direct hire
programs so those programs
you don't actually form a a strict
cohort because not everyone's starting
on the same day
but really they usually form loose
cohorts and they still have
mentors and buddies and programming
and opportunity to connect with each
other and connect with
alumni relaunchers who are in the
company and so there's
structure around around the program so
that's what these programs are and you
can hear the different names repower and
reunite
and uh re-empower and uh
uh re-entry and return to work um so
they all have those
kinds of names but at this point we've
had over 600 people participate
in task force company programs and 86
of them have been hired so we know this
is a very successful model
we already knew it because we work with
a lot of wall street companies where
um there's a high concentration of
return to work programs
in finance and wall street before it
emerged
um in the tech sector and the results
there are also
you know between 50 to over 90 percent
of
of cohorts on wall street were
converting to um
employees or extended higher so um
it we know it's a great model and um and
the direct hire programs have also uh
been really successful so
we meet every month with the program
managers
of the companies that are creating their
programs and we bring them through a
curriculum and share best practices
and um have an idea exchange and
everyone's building their program in the
same time frame
so the program managers themselves are
in a cohort
exchanging ideas and collaborating and
getting
the subject matter expertise as they
move along
creating this program so it's been
really successful and we've seen
many of these programs expand across
they may start in
in a tech area in i.t or engineering
and then they'll broaden functionally
they'll broaden domestically
and internationally and
uh and i know uh there's there's a lot
of questions coming in
what are the top three characteristics
you could tell us
make a successful relauncher what do you
what do you what do they
what do you see in people that you're
like i know you know i know that
sometimes i get a sensation
or a feeling that i know i just feel it
and then i certain
characteristics i see what do you see in
people that you're like yes this she's
gonna work he's gonna make it
all right well let me just first tell
you just in general what does the pool
bring to the table why are employers
interested in this pool um usually
as i mentioned these these um
initiatives start as diversity
initiatives so it could be
all of a sudden we don't have enough
women in mid to senior level roles
because
over a long period of time the women
have been dropping out
and that's why the programs on wall
street emerge first
because those companies are so old that
they've had generation after generation
of
people go through and the women were
leaving and all of a sudden it was like
a crisis we just don't have enough women
and and we want a way
we can reconnect with them mid-level so
that was the birth of the of these
programs
the tech firms of course the legacy tech
firms dell ibm
um they they're older companies but
you know the silicon valley companies
are younger and
some of them are just now 20 years old
so they're just getting
uh you know people moving through all of
the life stages maybe
a couple of times now so if you think
about our life stage
so we we're educated we have great work
experience
we have a mature perspective we're not
trying to find ourselves
like i actually think people younger
should be exploring around and trying a
lot of different things but people who
are relaunching
have already done that and so they've
learned a lot about themselves and when
they're coming back second time around
they we encourage them to do a lot of
thinking and deliberation about exactly
what they want to be doing now
on and they're very committed on and
the other thing is is that relaunchers
are chomping at the bid to get back if
they've been away for a long time um
they can't wait to get back and they
have this enthusiasm
and energy about being at work that
employers
always comment on how they inject this
enthusiasm into their teams
um so so that's another piece of it but
those really successful relaunchers
they have to be fearless learners they
have to be
open and not afraid to learn on new
technology like the employers will say
it's not as important for the person to
know all of the technology that we're
using
but i have to feel like the person is
fearless about
learning what they don't know so so
that's great
yeah the other thing that's important is
we're probably going to be older than a
lot of people we're working with
so when i went back i was 42 years old i
was working for a 37 year old
okay everyone was younger and you know i
i was along i went to the orientation
with the analysts right out of college
and the mbas and then there was me
um and and i have a really good attitude
about that
and i did and and i was like not hung up
and saying well
you know when i was your age we did all
those calculations by hand
so um i think it's really important to
um be you know very open and giving
and a team player and not hung up on
wow everyone's so much younger and that
if you're not hung up on it
they'll be less yeah on it so yeah i
think that's a great point i think
sometimes
there's a lot of factors that come into
play but that little bit of ego where
you have to say you know
i don't care that my manager is 10 years
younger or i don't
you know i'm going to take a little
longer to maybe learn this one thing and
that's
okay and not feel like oh i've taken a
step down if you've gotten back
you're going to get in there you're
going to prove yourself and you know
within months
you're going to see yourself if you're
if you're motivated and you're there and
you've got that growth mindset you're
going to see yourself
you know back on that trajectory where
you want to be yes
good so let's um what uh one of the
questions that came through that i
noticed was
talking about and i've had this a lot
actually and i keep meaning to ask you
carols
internationally i know we've got a lot
of these programs in here in america
uh udacity is a big international
student base what are you seeing
internationally
yeah all right so um the first
return to work program actually the
first return ship program
was with goldman sachs in 2008 and
actually and sarah lee ran a program in
2008 too but then they got restructured
and that program went away but the
goldman program endured
but in 2005 2006 there was
this initial wave of return to work
programs that didn't involve internships
lehman brothers had one
ubs had one that one actually re-emerged
in later years called career comeback um
tuck dartmouth business school was doing
a return to work program in conjunction
with
money from citibank so there was
activity then
so so that was the origin of the u.s
programs and then
they kind of grew from there um but the
international the other hotbeds
of relaunch activity that we're seeing
are in the uk
and in india that that's that's where
we're seeing the most activity
and when we look at the expansion of
programs that originate in the united
states
we will see them expand to the uk and
india
probably more more frequently than other
companies
although there are some company programs
uh
like um mastercard's program runs in
10 different com countries
internationally and in some really
interesting places like russia and dubai
um and johnson johnson's program
um has expanded internationally i i know
they they have someone from switzerland
they're just now expanding to india
um and a number of the programs ibm's
program expanded to india
commence did and so we've seen um a lot
of
activity uh and expansion there those
are the two
big areas okay
great and i think you know just so
everyone is again thanks everyone for
coming
i know there's a lot of questions we are
going to make sure we copy and paste all
of those we're going to be having a
uh revisit the relaunch shall we say um
i know carol is very busy
and we appreciate all the time you're
putting in today but we will
there's a lot of the questions i think
that the coaches we can have another
session and come up with if they're
i relaunch specific i'll definitely be
getting back in touch with you to make
sure i get the right answers for
everyone
tell us just i feel like i'd be uh
i'd sound it seemed like i was on a
deserted island by myself if i didn't
bring it
up uh covid and how's the factor in
everything in life and then
so if you can talk a little bit about
that and then i'd like to share a slide
that has a lot of your resources that
maybe you can tell them about some of
the upcoming events that might be of
interest
but what about covid how is it affecting
somebody
so it's been fascinating to watch this
so you know we're we
we're really deeply engaged with
companies
in that are contemplating programs
launched their first pilot
they've been running their programs for
a year and now years and now they're
expanding
so we we are involved with the whole arc
of programs in different stages
and i would say that we've seen programs
that
uh like td banks program we have a an
employer speaker series and we just had
um pauline ashford from td bank talk
about how they launched their program
during covid
and this was a 16-week program return
ship on that started in january and
halfway through
they they went to a virtual model so
they actually extended the length of the
program
um and they worked really hard to
have their managers engage you know
addition with additional engagement with
their relaunchers but i can't say
that they the managers were coached so
significantly different to
engage with their real entrepreneurs
than they were with everyone on their
team
right so so we saw that uh we do a lot
of programming with them
we did a a an extra session
you know so so we saw that happen um and
then
um we but we also saw uh we had
lucida plummer speak from jp morgan's
re-entry program
and that program launched
virtually so they hadn't started yet so
so they launched virtually
and they ran the whole program virtually
they shortened it a little bit
uh and um changed the way that they did
some of their programming so people
aren't sitting especially in orientation
all day from
you know start to finish um in sessions
there's breaks and
and it it's uh uh it's distributed
slightly differently than it would have
been if it was in person
um and we've we just saw uh facebook
just um hired an onboarded uh
their spring cohort completely virtually
um
and we are just now seeing and july 31st
is the deadline for some of these
programs what we're seeing facebook
lockheed martin on uh
raytheon technologies uh and northrop
grumman a lot of
defense activity um uh those programs
have all been
actively recruiting right now and
they're all launching in the fall
anywhere from late august to the
beginning of october
uh and then we're seeing oh and i'll
talk about this a little bit so we run
the i relaunch return to work conference
we've run it 26 times since 2008 and
have
over 8 500 people come to this event in
aggregate and it's a
intensive day of career re-entry
strategy for the participants
and then the opportunity for employers
to
um interact with the relaunchers who are
there and hundreds of
relaunchers come and employers sponsor
it because
they're interested in hiring relaunchers
so we
we usually run into university we run it
in new york at columbia we run it at
northwestern
on in chicago we've run it at stanford
in california a few times
we were about to run it at mit in boston
for our very first time
now they're virtual for our first time
we're going to a virtual model
we've condensed three conferences into
two we have
one october first and second one
november 19th and 20th
and accenture is the lead sponsor for
the november conference
morgan stanley for the seventh year in a
row is the lead sponsor
for our october conference and there'll
be
multiple other companies involved and
they're all there with recruiting goals
in mind
they either run most of them run their
own in-house programs
some of them are there because they
don't have a program but they simply are
interested in hiring re-launchers
and the other big piece of it is this
intensive career entry strategy
that we deliver we really pride
ourselves on the quality of our content
and we're doing something a little
different this year we're delivering
some of the content
ahead of the event um and some of it is
going to be live on the day of the event
and i'm
i'm glad you put this up on angela
because we actually anyone who's
interested in this event
uh we have an early bird rate 129
which we're calling an all-access pass
to both conferences
um and that is going to expire on
saturday august 1st so if you want to
save the 50 uh then i urge you
to um register before saturday i'm glad
we squeezed you in before the first i
know it's good
i felt like i'm thinking about you
squeezed us in
good time um yeah so um
do you so that anyway so that's kind of
so basically what we're seeing with
kovid
is that i don't want to say it's
business as usual because there's been a
lot of tweaks to these programs but
by and large the relaunch activity is
continuing
as we've seen it before now keep in mind
that at least at our client base but
this really
reflects on the real corporate activity
in general
we see a lot of activity in the finance
sector
and in the tech sector companies that
are
are probably less impacted by covid than
you know if there were airlines or in
the hospitality or hotel business
so some of that is is reflected in terms
of
what sectors they're in but programs are
continuing
and um companies are you know the same
way they moved
everyone home who didn't take career
breaks who are virtual they're making
changes to their relaunch program and
making them virtual too that's good
that's that's really good news good to
hear that those are everything's
progressing
a little bit differently i know i've
been doing some training with some
intern programs
in around the country that are all
remote and so we just all learned to
learn a little bit differently uh as you
can you see here
and and carol has mentioned some of
these resources i highly recommend
watching the ted talk
also free resources right you can watch
the ted talk the the podcast wherever
you listen to your podcast
um are obviously some great free
resources a lot of great resources on
your website i know that
all of this udacity coaches often
recommend
and then the the book is out there some
articles
i think yvonne if you can put the i
relaunch those lists of websites so they
can get to those and and have access to
those a little
handier in the chat and yes it's added
okay fantastic thank you i know we did
not get to all the questions
but carol thank you so much we are going
to have our
for the udacity students who are on
please um keep an eye out we'll make
sure you all get an email letting you
know
that when we're going to have our
revisit of this topic
and again there's a lot of things that
are i
that are re-launch specific but also
just just getting a job after
for whatever reason you you're switching
career paths and there's a lot of great
resources here and we'll make sure we
get back onto these questions and and
answer some of your questions and
open it up more as well please let me
know if there are any that
you want me to answer behind the scenes
that you can then relay back to the
group and also i want people to know
that we have
a relatively new job board where we
already have a bunch of companies on it
and hundreds of relaunchers so
um you might want to upload your resume
there too
yes thank you for that that's great i
forgot about that so
again thank you all so much carol thank
you it's really i really enjoyed it i
feel like we could uh
talk even longer but i know your
schedule's busy and you've got a big a
couple big conferences coming up that
a lot of different type of scheduling
that needs to take place
all right well thank you so much for the
opportunity to have the conversation
angela and i'm good luck to everyone out
there on their relaunch and it's great
that you're
enrolled in udacity courses so that's
going to help you
thank you thanks a lot everyone have a
great day and good luck in your udacity
courses and
on the job search we'll talk to you soon
all right bye
bye